um so one of the things i'm quite  excited about is that if you look at  some of the biggest problems that  politicians have got to face in our  world today whether it's climate change  or how to make trade fair or  how to  make natural resource exploitation you  know work for the north and the south um  what you're looking at i think is a  change in the way that we as people hold  our governments to account um to what  they do overseas as well as domestically  and what excites me is that we're no  longer in this old-fashioned situation  where you know i'm a brits british  people just talked to the british  government i'm now uniting with  brazilians and indians and australians  and americans and together we're  articulating a kind of fairer world that  we want our governments to co-create and  i don't think we're going to see this  change manifest immediately but when it  does i think this is when we start to  see  a new and a more effective breed of  global politics  you